ايضا الى كلمه لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينك
اننا اصبحنا اكثر اتصالا
وتعاونا مع اسيا الوسطى
لتلبيه احتياجات شعبها والولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بدعم هذه المهمه من الامور التي
اكدنا عليها على مدى سنوات ان الاستثمارات
التي نقوم بها في هذه الشركات تفيد
شركائنا ولكنها ايضا تفيدنا نحن في ايجاد
اسواق جديده لنا لمنتجاتنا ولاستثماراتنا
ولاجاد فرص جديده
للشراكات مع الدول وتلبيه او مواجهه
تحديات مختلفه
وتطوير علاقات جديده تفيد
بلادنا في مختلف
الجوانب الاجتماعي لهذا السبب اتي الى هنا
واؤكد ان المساله ليست مساله زياره واحده
بل هي مساله نتابعها
يوميا من خلال سفارتنا ومن خلال المجتمع
المدني ونحن نواصل هذه العلاقه
شكرته
الحكومه على وسادتهم لافغانستان من
كهربائي
وايضا الفتيات
وايضا
ستواصل الولايات المتحده دعمها لاعاده دمج
مقاتلينا افغان كانوا في
سوريا وعادوا الى بلاد موسى نعمل على
دمجهم وايضا هناك صعوبه توجه الكتر وخاصه
هنا في اسيا الاستاذ
التي تعاني من تبعات الاعتداء الاخير
على
اوكرانيا وايضا في باكستان
هذا الامر اثر كثيرا من خلال ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والغاز وايضا هناك اكثر من 60
مليون دولار قيمه المساعدات الغذائيه التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده هذا يجعل
سخاء باكستان مهمه
سخاء اوزباكستان مهم جدا
وتعودها مهم جدا ايضا في اعقابي العدوان
الذي قام به بوتن وبعد هذه
العلاقه التعاونيه
وايجاد المساعده فماذا سيوقف روسيا من
القيام بخطوات المسيله مع دول اخرى غير
اوكرانيا ان شركائنا وحلفان في العالم
وقفوا معنا ولهذا السبب نحن نلتزم ونبقى
ملتزمين للدفاع عن سياده اوكرانيا
واستقلالها وليس اوكرانيا فقط ولكن كل دول
اسيا الوسطى شكرا لكم
شكرا لك
بدايه قلت
ان هناك
تشكيك
برغبه موسكو في التفاوض
وهل وانتم والحلفاء تساعدون اوكرانيا في
ساحه المعركه هناك اجتماع هنا وفي مجموعه
العشرين وهناك من يودون ان يروا
ملاحظه سلام تبدا قريبا ونامل ونتوقع ان
يزداد هذا الضغط كيف
تتعاملون مع هذه المساله وايضا الصين
وتعليقها على الموضوع وتشكيككم بالدور
الصيني
التحدث الى
الاطراف وما هي الصيغه التي يتم فيها فتح
الحوار
ساجيب الجزء الثاني لن ليس هناك خطط
لان نكون في مجموعه العشرين لكننا ربما
نختار في
مجموعات عمل جانبيا
اما الامر الثاني فما من احد بحاجه لسلام
بشكل حسيس كالشعب
الاوكرانيوم امس
راينا المعاناه وراينا دول
كثر تعاني من العدوان الروسي نحن نعلم ما
هي الحقيقه البسيطه
يمكن للجيش الروسي ان يغادر اليوم قبل امس
قبل الغد ان قرر بوتين ذلك
طرف معتدي وهناك ضحيه وان كان هناك اي
تعادل بين الطرفين
ومن يكون اكثر التزاما بالسلم اعتقد
ان هذا هذا التوازن صعب جدا ثانيا
روسيا والرئيس بوتين كانوا فعلا فعلا
صادقين في رغبه بالدخول في دبلوماسيه
ومفاوضات بالطبع سنكون اولا الاطراف التي
تعمل بهذا الاتجاه لكن ليس لدينا اي دليل
على ذلك بل كل الادله في الاتجاه الاخر
ولنسمع لما يقوله بوتين فهو قال مؤخرا
وعلنا انه
حتى تعترف
اوكرانيا
بالحقيقه الحقائق الجديده على الارض فلن
يقبلوا بالانسحاب فهم يصادرون الاراضي اذا
تبعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذه الكلمه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكين